I'm guessing Kaden doesn't care about
people knowing his location now that his
bomb is about to go off he's almost on
the I 86 he's psycho but he's a smart I
mean he doesn't wanna be anywhere near
the boom everyone goes before one more
attachment I have an idea
Barry Allen is hereby cleared of all
charges and ordered release from iron
Heights penitentiary immediate hey
everybody this is gonna be my arrow
episode 13 video I know we got to catch
Katie James real fast hang on I got an
idea real quick hopefully those clips
give you an idea for the timeline
between this moment on arrow when Oliver
made that phone call in this moment on
the flash when Barry just got out of
prison
you guys know that I'm free I don't care
what I do I'm just so happy to be back
with all of you again team flash
[Music]
today we celebrate berry tomorrow we go
back to stopping the man that framed you
so I would say probably the biggest
surprise though is the quickness with
which they wrapped up this Caden James
storyline
I think after last week's episode we all
expected that it would be Richard Dragon
that was pulling the strings from behind
but I think the reason why they probably
got rid of Michael Emerson so fast is
because as a character as a guest star
he's amazing he's fantastic actor but
the problem is is that he's also really
expensive so I think it was to their
benefit to use him as much as possible
within a short arc and then just set up
a much bigger villain that didn't cost
them quite as much they can use a little
bit more and is a little more available
because as with martin stein on legends
of tomorrow like there are certain class
of actors that are so popular and so in
demand that it's just really hard to get
them to stick around for like an entire
23 episode season so if you ever wonder
why there's like a really famous actor
like Wentworth Miller Captain Cold it
just doesn't stick around for every
single episode it's stuff like that they
cost more maybe they don't want to hang
out in Vancouver as much because they're
based in Los Angeles there's all kinds
of reasons why actors leave TV shows
speaking of which Colton Haynes will be
coming back pretty soon in addition to
wrapping up that Kate and James
storyline they also did a little table
setting letting you know what the
relationships and the big arc is gonna
be for the rest of the season is
basically the divided team arrows vs.
Richard dragon so obviously one of his
big sticking points when he was talking
to Kate and James before he killed him
in that police station was is that he
was proud of the fact that he had
fractured the team into a million pieces
so they just let you know that they have
to fix that team before they can take
him down so eventually they'll get back
together but in pursuit of that drama
they also set up that Black Canary
versus black siren arc
we got their stuff another pair of
doppelgangers you know I have to say I
was surprised your boyfriend and his
little magical healing abilities you
know I thought it would be harder to
take him down but it wasn't and once
this is all over the Keating James
doesn't kill her I sure hope I'm gonna
take my shot now she's the main reason
why team arrows divided because Dinah
still blames Oliver for allowing Vincent
to be killed so vigilante is still a big
sticking point for Dinah it's gonna be
that way for probably the next couple of
episodes they were posting some
behind-the-scenes pictures of them in
the woods so this is just more black
siren versus Black Canary they're gonna
be a couple of alley cats just clawing
each other's eyes out for the next
couple of episodes and I've been waiting
for something like that for a while like
you don't have two characters with the
exact same powers in all the stuff that
went on behind the scenes when Katie
Cassidy left the show at people being
upset about them bringing a new black
canary on so it's almost like every time
black siren fights black canary there's
this really crazy meta thing going on it
is my great hope that at some point in
this season or next season probably next
season that they can have a Sarah
crossover into a legit birds-of-prey
episode but I don't think they're gonna
be able to do that this season because
wally west posted this picture they're
getting ready to film the legends of
tomorrow finale then he comes back to
the flesh for the last couple of flash
episodes and then I think we probably
won't see a Sarah crossover on arrow
until they sort of resolve this black
siren arc but they're really trying to
play it fast and loose with how she's
going to integrate with the rest of the
characters given her past like she used
to be this hardened criminal she was
working for zoom we saw her during flash
season two but they did give her some
more dialog like Katie Cassidy has had
very little dialogue this season on
arrow like eventually you know they're
gonna buy in some form of redemption
Quentin says there's a little piece of
my little girl inside of you I'm gonna
do whatever it takes to get it out so
he's gonna have to stash her in a
basement somewhere showing her power
points until she either goes crazy or
starts to relent a little bit the big
richard dragon explained her at the end
of the episode was just to let you know
how much stuff he has his hooks in in
star city so he has control of the new
police chief meaning that he'll be able
to
evade police detection like he's not
gonna be hauled in by any police
officers any time soon number two he has
control of a couple city officials and
the reason why that's important is it
because they have that ordinance that
they just passed were they outlawed
vigilantes so he can use them to push
through that legislation a little bit
quicker and make it harder for team
arrow to come after him so team arrow
coming back together redeeming black
siren and taking down richard dragon is
effectively what the rest of the season
is gonna be all about they'll just
double down on that but they haven't
given us any clues about who the season
7 villain might be like Oliver says we
don't execute people so I don't think
they're gonna end the season with him
straight up killing Richard dragon but I
do think they'll find a way to kill him
like usually Oliver has a moment like
that but then something else happens and
somebody else kills the character so I
do think that Richard dragon might wind
up dying at the end of the season
usually the only thing that can get
Oliver to walk that rule back like I
don't kill people as if they put
somebody he really loves in danger like
when Felicity's life is being threatened
or when Williams life is being
threatened he would definitely kill
someone to save Williams life but here's
the big reminder Roy is coming back in
episode 15 I believe he's back for two
episodes so it might be 15 and 16 then
Nyssa al Ghul is coming back separately
for another episode later this season in
a League of Assassins adjacent storyline
there's another shadow organization with
former League of Assassins members that
they just cast but just a reminder that
Rachael Ghul is supposed to be a
character on Titan season 1 so I'm
expecting them to push away from League
of Assassins a little bit more they've
kind of been laying off of them as an
organization in the arrowverse lately
but if you didn't see it the actors that
played Beast Boy and Raven were posting
pictures from behind the scenes there's
actually a picture of Beast Boy holding
the camera if you look at the edge of
this photo his hand is green that's
because they're in hand in makeup so
this is before they go to film some
episodes with him turning green and
turning into some other creature or
something like that because that hand
looks pretty gnarly but I do love the
way that she's giving him the side eye
the way that comic book Raven always
gives Beast Boy the side eye but I still
don't think they're even close to being
halfway done filming their episodes I
actually just saw a recent update that
they're filming till the end of May not
the end of April so they're even further
behind that I thought they were if you
want to learn a little bit more about
that just check the home page of my
youtube channel and my titans playlist I
did a video about when they might
actually drop episodes but there is a
new round of that blast ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and share the video using
those tools on the watch page announce a
winner when I post new DC that should be
in the next couple of days there's a
couple Marvel videos that I have to do
so I'll do some Jessica Jones season 2
trailer and some new Avengers infinity
war real soon but this will blow you
guys mind I actually have video of
Superman's black costume from Justice
League like they literally did do the
black costume but obviously a lot of
things got cut from that movie so I'll
post that video next it should be up in
the next couple of hours so click here
for my new flash video and click here
for brand new Avengers infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight